Hey everybody.
This is Wesley Chun,
engineer and developer
advocate at Google.
In this video we'll walk
through a simple script that
lists the files on
your Google Drive.
But before we do that,
why the drive API?
We're not talking Google
Apps, syncing files,
or a user Interface integration
using the Drive SDK.
No.
The API is about unlocking
drive functionality and making
it accessible to
your app-- things
like uploading and downloading
files, sharing, folders,
metadata, and
managing revisions.
With the API, you can write
an app that takes a zip file,
decompresses the archive, and
uploads those files to a Google
Drive folder.
Or take a stack of photos on
Drive, build a collage, or two
and upload the generated
image back to Drive.
Wait, here's an
even better idea.
All right, how many of you have
a massive folder of pictures
from different times and places?
A headache to sort.
Well, what if you could write
a little piece of code that
used the file timestamps
and the embedded geocoding
metadata in each file image?
Well, is it not past
well then to just auto
create photo albums out of
thousands of unsorted images?
Well, these are all
possible with the API.
The simple script we're building
today is just the beginning.
It's your launch point.
The code we'll
write is in Python,
but you can use
any language that's
supported by the Google
API's client library
because the calls are similar
regardless of which language
you use.
When using Google APIs,
you're either going to need
authorization or you don't.
For example, doing a generic
search for YouTube videos
doesn't require authorization,
but accessing your Google Drive
and updating your
YouTube playlists
do because that's personal data.
And there are code
snippets for each case.
So use the right
one for the job.
For us, because we're
doing Drive today,
you're going to be
using the authorize one.
Click the link to check out the
earlier episode on this topic
if you missed it.
Since we're looking at code,
let's go to the computer
and write that script.
OK.
In a previous episode, we
looked at the boilerplate code
that provides authorized
data access to Google APIs.
The code is going to be very
similar, or exactly the same,
to talk to any API
requiring authorized access.
So you should get comfy with it.
Today we're going to use
the Google Drive API.
So to start we copy the
boilerplate code here
as drivelist.py.
You can call it
whatever you like.
In this episode,
we want to list out
the files in a drive folder.
It's user data, hence
requiring authorized access.
You can't get to this kind
of data with just an API key.
Below the imports, the
first thing you need to do
is set the scopes
variable on line five.
Depending on what
you're trying to do,
you may need one or more scopes.
So either you'll have
an interval of strings
or one long string with
multiple scopes space-delimited.
The only scope needed
drive.readonly,
and that's all we have
for the scopes variable.
You can get a list of
scopes from the API stocks
page or OAuth Playground.
Line six is a client
secret file that you
save when you click the Download
JSON button on the Projects
Credentials page.
When access is
granted to an app,
you're given an
access token which
is stored in the file
listed on line eight.
Because we'll be running the
script for the first time,
we've got no
credentials, meaning
that we're going to fail
this if statement on line 10.
That initiates the OAuth flow.
Once access is granted, we need
to create a service endpoint.
And that's done on line 14.
The API string is
drive, since that's
the API we're trying to
access, and at the time
of this recording
it's on version 2.
So we'll use v2 for the version.
The last parameter is
using our credentials
to sign our HTTP request with.
Once everything executes
successfully now
we'll have an endpoint to
access Google Drive with.
We want to pull
down a user's files,
so let's create
a files variable.
And we'll use a service
endpoint to get access to that.
We'll use the files
call to get file access.
Then we'll use the list
method to get a list of files.
And then we'll
execute that command.
And if all goes well,
we'll get a payload
that comes back that has
an items field in it.
But just in case, we'll give an
empty list so that our for loop
doesn't fail down below.
Now we want to iterate
over each file.
For every file in files,
what are we going to do?
We're going to display
the file's name, which
is given with the title field.
And we'll display
its type, which
is given with the
MIME type field.
And that is pretty much it.
We actually should
be good to go.
So let's give it a shot over in
the command line window here.
By the way, if you want to
know what other data you
can get access to from the
API, just check out the docs.
Now let's run it.
Go through the OAuth flow,
get some credentials,
and see some Drive files.
By the way, before
I execute this,
at the time of this
recording you'll
get a warning saying that
the tools.run function is
deprecated, which is true.
There is a newer
function called Run Flow,
but it requires additional
code on the Python side.
We will look at those
changes in another episode.
So for now, let's just
use tools.run as is.
It's not quite dead yet.
There's lots of code that still
uses it, but at some point
it will be taken away.
So when we run
this command, we'll
see our browser window pop up
to go through the OAuth 2 flow.
And you can see it come up here.
Now instead of getting
the OAuth 2 window,
if you actually get
a 401 error saying
you're missing an application
name or email just
go to your Projects
Consent screen page
and fill out those two fields--
all the others are optional--
and save it.
And then you'll be able to
get to this exact screen here.
Once a user accepts,
a valid access token
is sent back and saved
in the storage.JSON
file on lines 8 and 12.
And then it'll just
execute our code down here.
So we should see a bunch
of Drive files pop up here.
And boom, there they are.
All right.
That was less than 20 lines
of code accessing your Drive
files, and it's
just the beginning.
Thinking about a mobile app?
Well, Drive has both
Android and iOS APIs.
Check out the developer
docs to find out more.
Well, we hope we've
inspired you in this episode
to see what you can
do with Google Drive.
This is Wesley Chun from
Google, and we'll see you here
next time on The Launch Pad.